do you ever get booed any like no rough
bombs like that um
no one time i was in philly and there's
some there was a place called the laugh
house in philly and it was a black room
on south street
and it was a cool room and i did my
buddies like hey if you want to go down
they'll give you like five minutes and
uh i mean i'm sorry if you want to go
down they'll give you 150 bucks and you
do like 15 minutes right you like you
co-headline or something so i go down
and it goes great
black audience goes great then he's like
hey man they want you back like the next
month it's like 150 bucks again you go
down your co-headlines so i get down
there
and it's packed and they're tired and
they're tired and there's so many comics
go on and then this one guy
who was a monster comic i don't know if
he passed away if he did rest his soul
his name was sugar bear
it was really [__] really funny like
a monster comic i don't he might have
passed if he did if he did rest his soul
but he goes on
and i go man this has been long he goes
on and he does like 20 something and
kills but they start to really get tired
he gets off and he goes dude now they're
tired so then i go on stage and i'll
never forget this i go on stage it was
actually i did a lot of
high pressure all black rooms where i
could be booed and this was the word out
of all of and i did it for many years
and it went well so this one didn't hurt
me that much but it still sucked because
but i get on and i go hey yeah i go dude
i just got back from kansas and this one
this one black woman in the audience
just goes why
and i remember going this is gonna suck
and do it i was up there and like people
were just like a cup like it was so late
like two people would just get up and
leave and then a couple other people get
up and leave and a couple of people get
up and leave and by the time i was done
i was like half the room and i was just
like and they paid me and said thank you
and i just remember being like [__]
[__]
and uh you know that that'll stay with
you but there you know it was there was
no booing it was just like oh okay it
wasn't like [__] you're not [__] i think
it was just like all right they're just
putting people on i'm tired he's not
killing the room the way you know i
would stay and it was one of those
things but i've had really amazing
experiences in rooms like that urban
rooms and stuff of course yeah white
rooms wouldn't put you up of course yeah
and anytime like a joke works in one
room but not like the other then like i
would get rid of it just because we want
to be able to entertain as many people
as possible you know but
there's a lot of
i don't in comedy there can be like a
lot of politics and things like that and
think what i'm so inspired about with
like what's happening at all things
comedy is it's like four comics by
comics run
and
there's producing opportunities for
comedians and it's so cool now more than
ever to see that there aren't
the gatekeepers as much you know like
trying to suck up to this booker or
trying to get in with this club or that
club which i was never able to do but it
seems like all those things are out of
control if you focus on what you can
control that's where you're gonna get
most of your opportunities yeah that's
true and and it's it's definitely let
you realize how silly it was to put that
much stock in those people i put eight
years into that you know
oh my god i hope they like me oh that
person that never did this oh that
person that never did [__] stand up
ever oh that person that loves their
power and loves to make you feel like if
you're funny or not and now they don't
have that you know it's almost like they
gotta [__] stand down it's like it's
like a hard-ass general that now has to
stand down
you know what i think it's like it's
like stan the [__] you don't have that
anymore and it's cool it's cool because
it lets you know
that not only was it silly but like
it
like here's the other thing too it's
like it's silly because if that person
loses their job and then it's another
gatekeeper then it's just another it's
the same thing it's the same person it
doesn't matter yeah it's like that
person oh yeah did you hear now greg
does it oh [__] greg's my [__]
yeah greg got hit by a train dude now
it's susan dude i got it susan's gotta
like me
susan pushed greg in front of a train
now it's her job yeah yeah susan got
shot in the face oh my god who's her
replacement let me go find it and it was
and it's all these people that don't
matter and and and i think covet made
people realize that i think that that
that youtube and all that made people
realize that it just doesn't matter
things that you think are a big deal
aren't just get stage time and get
better all you do is get stage time and
get better that's it get [__] better
write more jokes be more honest get
stage experience and you're gonna
[__] murder and then murder and then
murder and people are gonna see it and
go this person belongs in this room and
that's it
funny just get just get undeniable as
they say i think that's what barry cats
said yeah
that's the word everybody uses and it's
right just because you can't [__] with
that yeah you can't [__] with that
yeah that that's the thing is whenever
whenever i'm feeling a certain way and
then i see someone like you working i
was like oh there's so much more to do
in terms of like just the
just to see you
effortlessly perform for 75 minutes and
i'm just like watching it just like
it's like inspiring but it's also a
little
disheartening of like oh my gosh there's
so much more
to like learn and do like as a comedian
you know it's like it's like a
never-ending rubik's cube it's just what
i love about it but it's it's just
inspiring to be around comics at your
level and hope like learn a little bit
here and there but realize you know
there's over 400 interviews here and
comics reach out to me every day like oh
this episode helped me and i learned
this joke writing technique but the
number one advice is to get on stage
every comedian that's been on here the
number one advice has been you got to
get on stage learn it all but you've
really got to get on stage and put it
into action thanks for watching hot
breath the verse if you enjoyed this
clip subscribe to see our 400 plus
comedy interviews and check out this
playlist of our most popular clips